[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's seven o'clock this is a Sky News
special program on the war in Ukraine
our top story at a turning point the
verdict of the Ukrainian president as
Russian forces Edge closer to Kiev
foreign
digging in Ukrainian troops try to hold
their lines on the outskirts of the
capital
as Kiev prepares some major cities
including denipro come under attack for
the first time as Russia broadens its
assault
today they're digging and digging
filling sandbag after sandbag to try to
protect these features
we report from the southern city of
Odessa where residents are preparing for
a Russian assault
the U.N security Council debates
disputed Russian claims that Ukraine is
developing chemical weapons but the U.S
president has a warning of his own for
Vladimir Putin I'm not going to speak
about the intelligence but but Rush
would pay a severe price
Mr Putin meets his closest allies the
parent company of Facebook and Instagram
becomes the latest victim of the Russian
clampdown on foreign media
and we report from Poland as the UN says
more than two and a half million
refugees have now fled the fighting in
Ukraine
[Music]
a very good evening thanks for joining
us I'm Jonathan Samuels and this is a
special program on the war in Ukraine
the country's President Vladimir
zielinski said today that the conflict
has now reached a strategic Turning
Point as more major cities across the
country become caught up in the Russia
offensive the main focus however Remains
the capital Kiev with Russian forces
moving three miles closer in the past 24
hours according to a senior U.S defense
official well let's take a look now the
latest developments there's been renewed
fighting on the outskirts of the capital
and in the eastern city of kharkiv where
a psychiatric hospital was hit by a
Russian airstrike there's no word on
casualties but 330 people were at the
hospital
the knee Pro is the next likely Target
as Russia's Southern offensive moves
North
two other strikes near airports in the
western cities of lutzk and Ivano
frankovesk were also reported
Skies Katarina ritazzi has the latest on
today's developments
Russia hadn't prepared for this
with guns
an anti-tank missiles Ukrainian forces
repair an assault outside of the capital
Kiev
this fire fight was filmed yesterday
this is payback for the bombing of
marapol this Soldier says
according to British intelligence
unexpected Ukrainian ground resistance
is limiting the progress of Russia's
forces the foreign Fighters amongst them
seen by Russia as Western provocation
regarding the Gathering mercenaries from
around the world for Ukraine we see them
the Western sponsors of the Ukrainian
regime do not keep it secret they do it
openly disregarding international law
foreign
but how long can this resistance hold
out
Ukraine's president today made a
heartfelt appeal to the war weary
I know many people are feeling tired now
I understand it I understand it's all
about emotions and it's life when we
mobilize our efforts and when we can see
that we can win we expect the enemy to
fall quicker but the truth is in this
war the fight we need more time we need
more patience we need to be wise we need
to do our job the best we can to gain
the victory
but UK intelligence says Russia is
planning a fresh wave of assaults
this video was released by the Russian
army
they purport it shows their troops on
the move on the outskirts of Kiev
U.S defense officials say some Russian
contingents are now just nine miles away
other major cities are also under attack
captured on CCTV this morning Sky News
has verified this video from just before
6am
there's no obvious military Target here
this was a shoe factory
now it's Embers and Ash
as air raid sirens Blair civilians here
Scramble for safety Underground
more than 2 million people have now fled
Ukraine
those still here in besieged cities like
the northern khakib find shelter
wherever they can
in the southern Port City of mariopol
there is yet another attempt at
establishing a humanitarian Corridor to
help hundreds of thousands of people
safely escape a place where there's no
food and no fuel
the Russian army continues to do
airstrikes airborne and artillery shell
and and
their troops are behind the city and in
some districts of the city we have
Street battles so as you understand the
humanitarian situation decrease hour by
hour second by second
Ukrainian officials today appealed yet
again for international military might
to maintain a no-fly zone
the U.S president though clear and firm
they wouldn't support one we'll defend
every single inch of NATO territory of
the format of the United and galvanized
NATO
we will not fight a war against Russia
in Ukraine
the wrecked confrontation between NATO
and Russia is World War III
something we must strive to prevent
but as families cower in basements
there's the Specter of further
atrocities Russia says the US has been
making biological weapons in Ukrainian
Labs claimed the US and the UK say are a
fake story to cloak possible chemical
attack of Russia's own
fake story with very real victims living
in places where AID can't get in and
from where they can't get out
Catherine avatotsi Sky News
well our security and defense editor
Deborah Haynes is in the Viv in Western
Ukraine Forest this evening uh Deborah
what more can you tell us then about
these reports of a fresh wave of attacks
by Russia uh Russia really ramping up
the pressure
yes well I went to visit the site of one
of the attacks in the west we've had
over the last more than two weeks now of
this war the focus of the Russian attack
or offensive has been in the south in
the East and in the north obviously
encircling Kiev the capital but
overnight last night well in the early
hours of this morning actually about
sort of course to six this morning there
was airstrikes against two military
airfields in the west of the country so
an expansion really of the targeting the
belief is that it's a sign that Russia
is trying to take out the Ukrainian
ability to use its Air Force against
Russian targets which has been something
that Russia has failed to do since the
start of the invasion but also some are
interpreting this as a signal that the
that nowhere in this country is safe the
West has been more of a safe haven and
here in leviv it's been a real Transit
hub for those more than a million and a
half Refuge disease many of them coming
through this point to get into next door
Poland so an expansion there and then
also in terms of the the actual War
itself
and who's involved in it there are real
concerns from the Ukrainian side tonight
that Belarus might be about to get
involved you've had reports over the
last few days of
um concern over the posturing of
belarussians soldiers paratroopers on
the border with Ukraine Belarus a close
Ally one of the closest allies that
Russia has in the region and tonight a
warning that they might be launching
some offensive roundabout now that the
time that was given by the ukrainians
was nine o'clock local time which is now
um they said they accused Russia of
launching s or launching attacks from
Ukrainian airspace using Russian Jets
against belarussian villages on the
border and saying that could be some
kind of provocation that we've yet to
see if that would happen Belarus but the
Bella Russian president has denied that
his country would get involved but his
country frankly has is already involved
in terms of allowing its soil to be used
for Russian troops to launch their
Invasion and also to launch missiles
against Ukraine so it's already been
sanctioned because of that but that
potentially if that were to happen that
would be a serious deepening and
widening of this conflict bringing in a
whole other country albeit one very much
under the influence of Russia into the
conflict too
okay Deborah in leviv thank you and the
latest developments in the Russian
offensive will feature in Saturday's
papers we'll have our extended press
preview and news review from half past
10 this evening with tonight's news and
tomorrow's headlines joining us will be
daily Merit columnist Susie Boniface and
assistant comment editor at the Daily
Telegraph Madeline Grant
well taking over the city of Odessa in
the south of Ukraine is seen as one of
Russia's next strategic goals civilians
are joining in with the efforts to
defend the city against an amphibious
attack that could be imminent Sky's Nick
Martin is in Odessa from where he sent
this report
[Applause]
on the beaches of Odessa they're
preparing to defend themselves
they know the Russians aren't far away
now
[Applause]
[Music]
and who could have predicted this a
choir provides a wartime serenade to
volunteers
[Music]
everyone here just wants to survive
Odessa is a major port on the Black Sea
strategically important to Vladimir
Putin his invasion though has brought
life to a standstill here
precious monuments are now shrouded in
sandbags
just a little over three weeks ago it
was bustling here you know Odessa is
famous for its cafes and its restaurants
and its sort of Boutique shops but now
it's absolutely deserted and the one
thing that strikes you on every street
corner
are the barricades and behind me is the
famous opera house here in Odessa the
last time it was protected like this was
the Second World War
history really is repeating itself
on the street we meet an elderly couple
and I want to know what they think about
Russia's chances here there's a no-go
Russian army
no they'll not get through
back in Russia
also Daniel was born in Odessa his wife
and children have now fled and he's
staying to fight
I think you can hold back this Russian
offensive sure we're already shown since
24th that we're holding back and we we
kicked some ass sorry but we kicked some
ass
all right in odessa's Trendy Food Hall
they've turned it into an aid station
Inga a lawyer is organizing the effort
what's your message to Vladimir Putin
all of that message told the war is our
country go go away just doing anything
with your Russia everything you want but
never come again the grain we hate you
and all the politics we don't need your
support and then a reminder of the
dangers here one more scholarship would
last go so while we were in here about
to do an interview with the air raid
sirens have gone off so everyone's been
asked to go down into the shelter so
they're leaving this area now
a guy grabs a guitar and begins to play
[Music]
no one here knows what's gonna happen
next
Martin Sky News Odessa
[Music]
well the United Nations security Council
has held another emergency session today
with Russia making unsubstantiated
claims that Ukraine is developing
chemical weapons earlier the Russian
delegate was speaking and brandished
some images relating to the airstrike on
the maternity hospital in Mario pop
it's a building without windows but it's
not destroyed here are the photos
as well as to those who were inside the
building what would have happened to it
so we have the videos from inside the
building here they are
just that there is a disorder or
returned furniture and untouched
intact chairs once again can you imagine
what kind of Destruction would have
remained in the wake of a building hit
by a rocket or a bomb
well at the meeting both the U.S
representative Linda Thomas Greenfield
and UK representative Dane Barbara
Woodward reiterated their belief that
Russia was using these unsubstantiated
claims as an excuse to launch a chemical
weapons attack in Ukraine
I will say this once
Ukraine does not have a biological
weapons program
there are no Ukrainian biological
weapons Laboratories supported by the
United States we have serious concerns
that Russia may be planning to use
chemical or biological agents against
the Ukrainian people
the attempt intent behind these lies
seem clear
and it is deeply troubling
Russia has today brought into the
security Council
a series of wild
completely baseless
and irresponsible conspiracy theories
let me put it diplomatically
they are utter nonsense
our U.S correspondent Greg mylam is in
Washington for us sir Greg another un
meeting many will say lots of talking
lots of discussion but actually is there
any action
foreign
well this was a meeting called by Russia
and in many respects it's what the UK
and the US has been warning Russia would
do for a number of days the Prime
Minister yesterday of course speaking to
Sky News about this this suggestion that
Russia would allege that the U.S and
Ukraine were developing uh biological
weapons um dismissing as you heard there
dismissing that as as the truth but
saying Russia would use that as a
pretext uh to carry out a chemical
weapons attack of its of its own and and
the the UN the U.S ambassador they're
saying that even holding this meeting
was in many ways a false flag a pretext
that Russia was trying to create to
justify whatever they might do and
saying that it's Russia that has the
well-documented history of using
chemical weapons supporting president
Assad in Syria and his use of chemical
weapons they have a biological program
the U.S says that violates uh
international law and these allegations
from Russia have been around for a long
time but they really ramped up in the
days before The Invasion to create that
that pretext the question is what will
the West do about Joe Biden was speaking
earlier today unveiling some new
sanctions he said if chemical weapons
were used there will be a severe price
for Russia but we don't know what that
is and remember he was vice president
when Barack Obama talked about red lines
over chemical weapons in Syria and they
didn't take the action that people
expected
Greg in Washington thank you
well despite the continuing escalation
in the conflict Vladimir Putin said
today that there are certain positive
developments in talks between Russia and
Ukraine that assessment came as he met
his ally belarussian President Alexander
lukashenko in Moscow but in the latest
clampdown on access to foreign media
within Russia the social media giant
meta the parent group of Facebook was
labeled an extremist organization after
the company said it would temporarily
allow people to post calls calling for
Vladimir Putin's death our Moscow
correspondent Diana magnet has more
Russia's Minister of Defense Sergey
shoigu Distributing medals for bravery
pictures released for domestic
consumption to Rally the people behind
what Russia refuses to call anything
other than a special military operation
these Soldiers made it back from the
front others have not
but it's a criminal offense in Russia to
report anything other than the official
number which was 498 on March the second
and has not been updated since
according to Mr shoigu the operation is
going to plan in a meeting of the
security Council he told Russia's
president that there were 16 000
requests from so-called Volunteers in
the Middle East who wanted to help
liberate in his words the people of
donbass
a claim quickly backed up by this video
from Russia's Ministry of Defense of
Fighters chanting their support for the
Syrian president and for Russia
yesterday
Vladimir Putin went on to meet his
Belarusian counterpart Alexander
lukashenko a frequent visitor to the
Kremlin these days who declared that
Russia had acted not a moment too soon
foreign
storm the U.S imposed additional
measures removing Russia's most favored
nation trading status Banning further
Imports and the export of luxury goods
to Russia
luxury here has already shut down the
symbols of what it meant to get rich in
the 90s and the early years of Putin's
Reign all pulling out
Instagram was banned today the symbols
of connectivity in modern Russia
shutting down one by one
in Soviet times people tended to talk
about the system only in the safety of
their own kitchens it was too dangerous
to disagree publicly and it feels a bit
as though Russia is returning to that
state with the Kremlin today with this
message to anyone who might disagree
with what they are doing a true Russian
is never ashamed of being Russian if
anyone says so this person is not
Russian this person is not with us
many thousands of Russians have left the
country over the last two weeks
sanctions will rip away the Futures that
the rest expected they'd have
even if many may not really know it yet
Dana McNeese Sky News Moscow
this is a Sky News special program on
the war in Ukraine coming up after the
break we'll take a look at new plans to
help British people open up their homes
to Ukrainian refugees
[Music]
I'm Hannah Thomas Peter and I'm Skye's
climate change correspondent
the UK is a world lead
[Music]
as part of the Congo based rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of Africa we aim
to be the best and most trusted place
for me
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me I might be just very
neat but I do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
for the last 30 years we have known how
bad it is I'm not here to apologize I'm
here to fight for the next step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these the sofas and people's desks
and children's books and you can see
inside this home here people trying to
uh to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
I think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of this beauty
around us
the future of you and me
oh
foreign
[Music]
welcome back the UK government is set to
announce proposals to allow British
people to open their homes to ukrainians
fleeing the Russian invasion the new
scheme expected to be confirmed next
week will create a new sponsored
humanitarian route for those ukrainians
without family links here in the UK it
comes after Boris Johnson came under
increasing pressure across the political
Spectrum for failing to do enough to
help refugees from the conflict Sky's
Becky Johnson reports
we hope and pray that God gives you the
strength and courage to face these awful
times we stand with you she's collected
hundreds of messages and raised
thousands of pounds to send to Ukraine
but Lisa K wants to do more this room is
all ready for two children a British
family who fled from Kiev will arrive at
her home in Warwickshire this weekend
she wants to give her other spare rooms
to ukrainians
I'd like to be able to look after them I
think they've been through absolute hell
and for me it makes me feel guilty that
I can just sit here and have all this
space
and then there's those people that have
had to leave like their dads and
brothers and uncles and grandfathers
behind it it just really really gets to
me
the government says it'll set out more
detail in the coming days about how
British people will be able to offer up
their homes to Ukrainian refugees but it
follows heavy criticism of the home
office for the delays and red tape being
faced by people trying to get into this
country
at this Refugee support center they have
many questions we don't know the
logistics of this scheme yet
um and we don't know the LGBT criteria
how long they will be able to stay in
the UK hopefully access to employment
study and benefits
um and even better Refugee status
support to find employment registering
with the GPS good places for their
children this is my granddad Grandma my
aunt the details will matter to families
like Julius their Hometown now in
Russian control they escape to Poland
and are waiting to see if the UK will
allow them in she has this plea please
make it faster
because it's very time consuming for
elderly people and people with children
like in my case let them come and then
I'm sure that all of the documentation
can be handed in in the UK already where
they save
the British public have already shown
their willingness to help will that
extend to opening their homes to those
most in need Becky Johnston Sky News in
the West Midlands
and our Deputy political editor Sam
Coates is with me here in the studio and
Sam we're expecting a big announcement
from the government on Monday aren't we
about the whole Refugee situation that's
right Michael Gove the leveling up
secretary is in the lead he's going to
announce this resettlement package
people being able to open their homes to
people coming from Ukraine do their part
in this big effort in underpinning it
essentially is going to be a second
route for people to come in from Ukraine
at the moment you can come in
effectively if you have a permanent visa
and you come from Ukraine you can bring
in your extended family so there's a
family route from Monday there is going
to be a sponsorship route so what that
means is that if a local Authority or an
individual agrees that they're going to
house you look after you then you will
be allowed to enter the details of how
this will work will be complicated and
that's what Michael gave has been
setting out now the government's come
under Fire in recent days because some
of this stuff there's been criticism
from the opposition parties that it
wasn't fast enough quite a lot of fire
aim back actually at the Home Secretary
pretty Patel who has been cast in some
quarters as not being generous enough to
refugees what's interesting we've been
speaking to people across government
today at Sky and what's interesting is
that actually pretty Patel in some cases
has been pushing for schemes that we're
going to be a bit more open to more
people coming from Ukraine but the block
actually came in some cases in number 10
uh the number 10 policy unit and others
uh just going hang on a moment we want
to make sure everybody's properly
checked we've got to be careful about
exactly what we're opening the doors to
so perhaps not quite the politics that
some some were expecting in that but we
will get details on what number 10 think
are are very generous new scheme when
Michael Gove uh stands up in the House
of Commons on Monday okay we'll find out
more then Sam thank you for the moment
you're watching Sky News special program
on the war in Ukraine coming up after
Ukrainian forces that show off captured
Russian Vehicles I'll be talking to a
former US ambassador to Ukraine about
the latest developments in the
conference
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
this is a Sky News special program on
the war in Ukraine our top stories this
evening a senior U.S defense Source says
Russian forces have advanced three miles
closer to Kiev in the last 24 hours
but the United Nations America has
dismissed claims by Russia that it's
helping Ukraine make Chemical and
biological weapons
and the UN says more than two and a half
million people have now fled Ukraine the
UK government is planning a new scheme
to help British people take in refugees
uh well I can speak now to John Hertz
former U.S ambassador to Ukraine and now
director of the Eurasia Center at the
Atlantic Council good to see you this
evening thank you very much for your
time um and perhaps we can just start
with your thoughts uh 16 days in uh to
this conflict what is Russia's position
tonight there's talk of a a fresh wave
of attacks coming and also Belarus
getting involved
okay a lot the Russian offensive in
Ukraine has gone much worse than
anticipated
they have largely been bogged down
around marayuple around harkiv around
Keith
it is true though that over the past I
don't know 24 36 72 hours we've seen
some real movements in the south
and some movement around around teeth
uh but they've only taken at this point
you know almost two and a half weeks
into their major invasion
one significant Ukrainian City her song
in the south
even though they've actually been
surrounding Maru pool since almost
before this new Invasion began they
still haven't taken the city
what this means is that they're starting
to use the barbaric tactics they use the
chishnu and in Northern Syria which is
massive bombardment of Civilian areas
you I say not so much without regard for
civilian lives but to kill civilians as
well as kill soldiers and that way to
bomb their opponents into submission
this of course is a war crime as is
their use of thermobaric or vacuum bombs
and their use of cluster bombs
when you hear president zielinski say as
he has done in the last 24 hours the
Ukraine has reached a strategic turning
point he's convinced that Ukraine can
win but that surely is wistful thinking
certainly if if NATO doesn't do any more
well actually no I think that in fact
Ukraine is likely to win this conflict
but the question is how many more tens
of thousands or even hundreds of
thousands of ukrainians must die before
that becomes clear to the rulers in the
Kremlin
right now you have a war of one man
Vladimir Putin are the whole people
Ukrainian people it's pretty clear from
watching that bizarre video when Putin
announced his intention to to move
um and then watching his bizarre video
when he announced raising nuclear alert
that even his most senior advisors are
uncomfortable with this
and by launching this major Invasion
Putin has greatly weakened Russia
economically and geopolitically
oh he is United Europe and and nato in
ways he did not anticipate even Germany
now understands that Putin is a threat
to World Peace
and he has brought on his head and
Russia said sanctions which will crush
the Russian economy and in the middle
term and in the long term even the
Russian military because without it
without a real resources it's hard to
keep your military in shape
the only real question now is again how
much pain is he going to reflect on
Ukraine before his War there is
understood to be a failure he can reduce
Ukrainian cities to Rubble he can take
more parts of the country he will never
however control more than the cities and
the roads he have he'll haste if he
actually uh significantly reduces the
Ukrainian military he hasn't done that
yet which is also an important
achievement he will face a partisan War
which will take Russian lives Russian
soldiers lives add infinitum and at some
point the Russian people will realize
this is a loser of a war and even the
Russian Elite intimidated by their
increasingly authoritarian leader will
understand that Putin's policies are a
disaster for Russia so so in the long
term this is this is the demise of
President Putin that seems to to be what
you're saying but in in the short term
the ukrainians are going to be pummeled
aren't they in in coming days and weeks
you wrote I think um I'm writing saying
that you were part of a a letter to
President Biden asking for more to be
done what did you mean by that what what
exactly were you asking for
look the Biden team deserves credit for
accurately seeing the Russian threat
and laying out I would say a solid
framework for addressing it and and
mitigating it
but an actual implementation they've
been slow and timid
oh I I would say that's especially true
on the military side
uh you know they talked back in the
spring a year ago when you had the first
Russian build up about providing
additional arms to Ukraine they didn't
do it in the spring after the Russian
drawdown
um they only began to do it in
connection with this crisis in late
January we should have been sending
additional arms to Ukraine back in
certainly November or December well
before this new Russian invasion began
and even after the decision to send
additional arms to Ukraine we we waited
till the end of January to send our
first stinger missile to Ukraine that's
disgrace and now you have the
disgraceful decision by the
administration not to expedite the
sending of migs from our NATO allies
into Ukraine and they did it frankly
because they were afraid of quote
unquote the escalatory effect as Moscow
is bombing the hell out of Ukrainian
civilians they're talking about sending
warplanes to Ukraine as quote unquote
and escalation that is timidity parading
as Prudence isn't the problem that you
know who who decides uh what what an
escalation is we don't know what Putin's
thinking and his behavior has been so
erratic uh uh and so delusional in many
ways you know he may well see that as an
escalation
well I would hope he does see it as an
indication of American intent to defeat
him an actress American intent NATO
intent to help Ukraine defeat him in
Ukraine look at the logic of your
question if we have if we say well gee
Mr Putin May escalate therefore we have
to hold we have to hold our own
responses we're not only handing Ukraine
to Putin we're handing the Baltic states
the same logic would apply if Putin has
his designs on the Baltic states and why
would he think the chapter 5 would save
the Baltic states if he sees us cower in
responding to his clearly inhumane war
in Ukraine
so you're saying that we're almost being
held hostage by our decision not to
enforce a no-fly zone for example
that's correct and look Russia Today is
a great danger principally because Putin
is a Serial provocateur the Soviet Union
was a much greater threat to the United
States yet we were able to stand up to
the Soviets going toe-to-toe without
actually shooting over the balloon
crisis in 61 even more over the human
Missile Crisis in 62 there was no
nuclear Holocaust what emboldens Putin
is Western weakness we Western did not
the U.S did nothing after Georgia was
attacked by Russian 08 we did almost
nothing after Crimea was attacked we
began to do something after the war in
gun box began in 2014 but not enough
and while we've done a great deal now
and again you have to credit Biden with
that we have not done enough
you know if we had sense when Ukraine
asked years ago anti-ship missiles to
Ukraine
um Russia would not have made all that
progress in the South they would not be
bombing Odessa if we had sent anti-air
missiles not just Stingers but more
powerful missiles to Ukraine when they
asked years ago the Russian bombardment
over harkive over over Kiev would be far
less
our timidity has only emboldened Putin's
worst tendencies
he has one great advantage
in uh what two great advantages in this
war one of course is a pure nuclear
power of the United States and he likes
to threaten the West with that and two
he has a KGB operatives knows for
weakness and he smells when he can
intimidate his opponents and he's
smelling intimidation right now and why
do we want to feed that I just don't
know
fascinating listening to you you seem to
be echoing quite a lot of what president
zielinski has said in in recent days
Ambassador John Herbst thank you very
much indeed for your time it's much
appreciated thank you
well more than two and a half million
people have now fled Ukraine since the
Russian invasion started on the 24th of
February in Exodus which is contributing
to a growing humanitarian crisis both
within Ukraine as well as in neighboring
countries one of them Poland has seen
more than one and a half million
refugees enter their country alone
well Skies Lisa Holland reports now from
Walsall
I said this is this is this is what we
organized temporary
this is just one of the dozens and
dozens of refugee shelters being set up
in Warsaw
a welcome Camp bed after the bunkers and
the bombs and the days of travel
I love you I love you they long to be
home but family after family tells of
the trauma of escaping War
Julia struggled to reach Kiev train
station with her daughter who has
epilepsy and her son who's autistic
what can I say she says it was so hard
trying to hold my children's hands in
case they fell and carry the luggage
[Applause]
then she reveals 11 year old Nikita is
recovering from an operation after being
born with deformed feet she got here
guiding one of her children who's barely
able to walk
others at the shelter need medical help
a young girl is on a drip dehydrated
after the exhaustion of the journey to
Poland now made by a million and a half
people so the problem now because so
many refugees have come to the Polish
Capital because the authorities are so
stretched they're having to provide more
permanent accommodation or boss people
to other Polish cities
this Refugee crisis is defined as an
exodus of women and children across the
city they're a makeshift nurseries to
entertain the youngsters
and women distraught they'd left
husbands brothers and fathers behind in
Ukraine
Anna's left her husband in Kiev she also
has to contend with a mother-in-law in
Russia who refuses to accept why she's
fled to Poland
she said oh it's just uh
um little not big not big situation it's
just a little he said mom we had no
house Russian is a destroy our house
across Poland thousands of people who
needed no persuasion of the horrors of
this war are taking in refugees
English teacher Victor Johnson and his
wife offered a home to Marta and her
grandchildren both of the children's
parents are still in Ukraine I didn't
speak to Marta before she came here she
just turned up in the car
and so we met them with high fives and
hugs invited them in made them feel at
home
and that was the most important thing
that they felt safe secure
we asked Roman how he's settling in all
things considered okay okay nice
just one example of the kindness of
strangers in the midst of Lisa Holland
Sky News
you're watching a Sky News special
program on the war in Ukraine coming up
in a moment should the West be tougher
in standing up to Russian aggression
I'll discuss that with the
ukrainian-american international lawyer
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
more now on Ukraine and whether the
Western powers are responding
appropriately to Russia's Invasion and
I'm joined Now by Victor Rudd who is a
lawyer and chairman of the committee on
Foreign Affairs of the Ukrainian
American Bar Association thank you very
much for your time great to see you on
Sky News this evening thank you perhaps
we can start maybe with a bit of a
positive news Vladimir Putin today is
saying that there have been some
positive shifts in the negotiations with
Ukraine what do you think he meant by
that positive for which side
well you know it's a good question but
it really begs uh a slightly uh a
different question if I may it'll be
positive ultimately for him
because he's playing up to what is our
cultural and psychological DNA the
Anglo-Saxons in particular the the Brits
ourselves here the Canadians and we
think that agreements whatever they are
in the international context
uh are similar to domestic agreements
for Mercantile transactions and the like
and that there is some enforcement
mechanism and there isn't whatever
agreement that may be reached with
Russia uh there's just a history of
broken agreements uh it whatever is
agreed upon with Russia will either be
ultimately used to deny and prevent the
realization of what that agreement is
supposed to achieve
or the very opposite or just the stall
and buy for time
uh there is nothing to be achieved as
far as I'm concerned in talking and
negotiating with him without
understanding that that agreement will
not hold whatever the subject matter
yeah but I suppose it might it might at
least stop more people being killed I
mean there is some talk about zelenski
and Putin meeting together is that
realistic
I'm sorry I didn't hear the question
please yeah I was just going to say I
was just saying uh there is talk of
zelenski and Putin perhaps meeting
together is that realistic
well whether it will come or uh come
about or not I don't know uh does it
hurt no I think zelenski wants to have
that meeting fine uh but I uh very
honestly uh I would not uh hold out a
lot of Hope for anything constructive
coming out of it uh there's the
near-term immediate term satisfaction of
achieving something in a media term but
uh in a near term medium and long term
it'll never work
what about Belarus reports that Belarus
could well invade tonight I mean that
could be a worrying development
yes it could be but there is a
tremendous amount of
uh dissatisfaction in the ranks of the
uh Belarus conscripts and uh they're
going into this uh in their heart of
hearts I think uh even more reluctantly
than Perhaps Perhaps some of the Russian
conscripts which as you know themselves
are rather taken aback where they found
themselves and and what they're doing
let's talk about uh the no-fly zone uh
zelenski once again uh calling for that
no-fly zone desperate for more help from
NATO we know NATO at the moment are
holding firm but zelenski says they will
eventually capitulate NATO eventually
will have to do something as more
thousands of people are killed what's
your what's your point of view on that
yes thank you very much I I think sooner
or later is going to come to that kind
of Tipping Point and uh it's not just a
question of um a humanitarian concerns
uh but I have a very serious concern
about the uh take over the two power
plants in Ukraine by Russian forces uh
the possibility of a muskuroka false
flag operation involving either
a a nuclear uh event or a chembio event
that has to be prevented that's going to
spill over uh tremendously I understand
the arguments about a potential uh uh
encounter with Russian planes in advance
but let's understand as well that's not
automatic and if we take history as a
gauge uh you know Russia has always
always understood uh resolution or
resolve but if it's backed by muscle we
had the shoot down by turkey using an
American F-16 plane of a Russian
airplane back in I think it was 2015 in
2018 if I had my dates correct uh
American troops uh virtually decimated
Russian Commandos in Syria and there
really wasn't a whimper from Putin's
side I think that alternatively of
course is uh the delivery of the Polish
mix that a lot of people have been
talking about that to me was an
incomprehensible decision by uh by the
White House
but that's the alternative having
American Pilots flight a fly of course
you know their own planes
I think that uh the no-fly zone sooner
or later is going to have to come become
a reality and if we're going to weigh
the risks of encounter and engagement
potentially with uh with Russia we're
far better off doing it right now than
later on where the trade-off is going to
be worse when the odds of An Occurrence
or an encounter are going to be higher
and where the consequences could be
worse yeah it's very interesting what
you say and and you use some good
examples there but of course Putin seems
to be in a very different place now to
what he was in back then he seems really
backed into a corner now and when you're
backed into a corner uh you can do the
unthinkable
uh yes that is uh that that is a risk
there's a lot of talk about uh Putin and
a change of Putin and so on and so forth
uh I am a bit of an outlier because I
think what's only coming to the four
right now are his traits his mindset
that people were not seeing previously
it's becoming manifest but I don't think
the man has changed all that much at all
there's a lot of talk about him being in
an informational bubble the effect of
covet so on and so forth uh but if there
is one thing that he will understand he
does understand raw strength and
unfortunately for our mindset what we
consider to be a provocation in a normal
uh societal sense of the word a
provocation for Moscow always has been
and it's not just Putin but it always
has been even during the Soviet days a
provocation was a steel wall when we try
to avoid a provocation it's really a
green light it's the opposite we're
doing the opposite of what we think we
did I'll give you one or two examples
that of what we should have never done
at least by we I mean the United States
just before the Geneva Convention excuse
me the Geneva Conference in June
President Biden had an interview on
National Television in the United States
where he called Putin a killer after the
interview he picked up the phone called
Putin and apologized that was a huge
mistake
that was a psychological disaster it was
a disaster when we suspended a regularly
scheduled ICBM test when Putin started
rattling the nuclear threat I think it
was last week those are mistakes we
think we're doing good we think we're
tamping down the coals and the Flames
we're not we're stoking the fire there's
a you know Generations history that the
West has had in dealing with them with
Moscow as to what a quote provocation
constitutes yeah I do think that able
flight has to be done just fascinating
uh listening to you a very depressing uh
the whole thing Victor chairman of the
committee on Foreign Affairs of the
Ukrainian American Bar Association great
getting your perspective we appreciate
it thank you
coming up in the next hour here on Sky
News all the latest developments on
Ukraine as Russian forces are reported
to have advanced three miles closer to
the Ukrainian capital in the last 24
hours
[Music]
thank you